hi my name is Paul Rashidi and I'm with
the Google cloud platform team today
we're going to discuss how to build the
hello and points Android application
from scratch will be helped by a github
gist that will contain most of the code
we would normally write and commented in
as we talk about it so let's get started
the first step will take is setting up a
Cloud endpoints back in this is actually
pretty easy we clone a Cloud endpoints
back end sample from github like this
but do note there is also a Python
version available as well in order to
get the Java back-end running on our
local machine we'll perform two steps
will uncomment a line in this maven
pom.xml file to specify that we want to
run on all IP addresses on the local
machine this will allow our Android
application to access the backend
application since we'll be using an
emulator which can access localhost the
other change we'll need to make is
editing the App Engine web XML file to
update the app spot ID since we won't be
deploying remotely to App Engine this ID
is only affecting the Java package name
of our generated classes you should use
the developer console to register an ID
and use that value here
easy enough we'll save and exit
so just to quickly recap we only made
these two changes
now to run this back-end locally we will
invoke it via maven in this command
install is building our application and
the dev server command is running it on
a local dev server you should know the
first time you run this command on a
machine it will take a little bit longer
than normal because maven will download
the App Engine plugin now that our
server is running let's take a look at
it in our API Explorer this is very
handy if you're not familiar with an API
but still want to play around with it
we'll use this URL
we'll select our API and we'll run the
list command here
we see that our service is returning to
messages hello world and goodbye world
now that we have a working test server
let's get to the Android app we'll
switch to Android studio to create our
project the first thing we're going to
do is create a new Android application
via the new project wizard we'll adjust
some project names here and then select
a minimum API level of 8 the client
libraries that we will create will need
this minimum level we'll take the rest
of the defaults and create this project
I'll speed the video up a little so you
don't have to wait for the initial build
and there we have it this is the typical
default Android project with a single
main activity we'll just close a few
windows here and put focus on our github
gist this just contains all the code
that we are writing during this tutorial
so you don't have to watch me type you
can access this gist at the URL on the
screen let's just briefly look at the
files before we copy them into our
project first we have application Java
which we'll use as a way to sort
messages retrieved from our back-end API
you will want to use content provider
instead of a global variable like this
but we're doing this for sample code
simplicity the next file is a main
activity file all the code pertaining to
connecting to the back-end API is
commented out the code that is not
commented out influenced a simple list
adapter that will let us display
messages on the screen retrieved from
the backend API the next XML file
defines two GUI for the app we'll
preview this in a minute
this file contains a snippet of gradle
dependencies will use to complement our
client library classes this final file
is a simple move script that will move
these files into the right locations in
our sample project so now we'll flip
over to a new terminal window and
download this gist will also enable
permissions and execute our move script
and now the files we reviewed are in our
project well first take a look at the
main activity code we glossed over
before you can see the import statements
for the client library are throwing an
error that's because we need to generate
our client library let's do that now to
do this we'll flip back to our terminal
window we'll stop our backend API server
and we'll run this endpoints get client
lib goal via maven this will generate
the client library next we'll move the
zip file containing the generated Java
classes to our current directory
then we'll unzip it and move it to our
Android project source directory
then we'll restart our local back-end
API server
we'll now switch back to Android studio
and references Gradle build file
dependency snippet we're going to copy
this and paste it into the build Gradle
file for our project this will put all
the dependencies that the generated
client library code needs into our
project so that we can build and run
will now save and force a rebuild of the
project
you
if you still have some unresolved
imports you likely need to run the sink
project with Gradle function here
next we're going to look at the GUI
layout that we received from our gist
it's a simple layout with a simple
button for our back-end for each of the
API methods first we can get a message
by ID you'll notice we use the onclick
attribute to dynamically invoke methods
in our code next we have a button to
list all the greetings on the server
here we have a send greeting button
which maps to the multiply message on
the backend finally in this UI you'll
notice a list view at the bottom which
we'll use to display our messages you
probably also notice the sign-in button
and the authenticated message buttons we
won't talk about those in this video but
full details are and they readme it's a
full sample code I reference at the
beginning of the video well now close
this and go back to our main activity
code the first code we're going to
comment in is the on click list grading
method this method is invoked when the
list greetings button is clicked on the
GUI we just looked at you'll see we're
using an anonymously defined async task
to make our backend API calls on that
background thread we are first getting a
handle to our back-end API via this
utility method will then create a list
greeting command object and we
immediately invoke it to retrieve a
greeting
we passed the retrieved greeting back
from the method and then it's passed
back to us in the on post execute method
right here
in this method we'll use the display
greetings utility to display it in our
UI this line of code then kicks off this
anonymously defined async task without
any parameters will next uncomment on
click get greeting to implement get
green button functionality this looks
the same as before except for getting
the greeting ID parameter from the UI
here we format it for use in our API
call
and then we use the async task here
again finally we will comment in the on
click send greetings method to implement
the last button the only real difference
here is that we're pulling two
parameters from the UI instead of one as
before
now we'll take a look at some of the
utility code we used above this first
method is the one we use to get a handle
to our back-end API we're constructing a
builder object that was supplied by the
generated API classes we're using two
class variables here to construct our
builder let's comment those in above as
you can see we're commenting in Android
compatible JSON Factory and an HTTP
transport let's scroll back down in this
builder we have the capability of
providing a different route URI
this is a handy way of redirecting your
client library to point to your local
development or testing servers we're
going to do that right now with my IP
address this is so any API calls we make
will go against my local development
server from the Android emulator the
final code will comment in here is to
display greetings method this method
simply updates on this adapter to
display the greetings pass to it again
you typically want to use content
providers to store and provide data to
listed actors but we are simplifying
this sample code the code down here is
the list adapter we saw earlier in the
github gist nothing new we're close to
being finished I promise next we'll add
internet permissions to our Android
manifest file
we'll adjust our UI style to be dark
instead of the light one this will make
our content a little bit more visible
when we run it in the emulator we're
about done let's go ahead and start an
emulator we click here and create an
emulator any will do unless you've added
authentication to your API and in that
case you would need to select a Google
API emulator
we'll start the simulator and I'll scale
it so it fits on the screen remember to
utilize the accelerator extension in the
SDK manager if it is available for your
development platform okay now that we're
up and running with the emulator let's
make one last change we need to define
our custom application class in our
Android manifest I'll do that really
quick here and then we'll deploy to our
emulator
it's running I
the first thing we'll test is list
greeting we click the button and we can
see hello and goodbye world messages
these are the same messages we saw when
we use the API Explorer before now we'll
test get greeting by putting in an index
of zero and it returns the correct hello
world greeting from the backend API the
idea one returns two goodbye greeting
correctly as well then we'll test send
greetings by putting in a text message
and specified that it needs to be
repeated three times
and the back-end API successfully
returned our message here as well well
that's about it our tests are working
and our new Android application is
communicating with an API we're running
on our local server I want to thank you
all for your time the Google cloud
platform team looks forward to seeing
what you build with this and we look
forward to your feedback as well Thanks